so we took the spot GPS messenger which
is basically an emergency locator beacon
out into the wild to see exactly what
happened when you push the 9-1-1 button
I'd always wanted to push the button I
love pushing buttons and you've been
tempting me since I got the first one
about a year ago this time though we
coordinated the Tahoe Nordic search and
rescue and gos the company they use to
actually dispatch the rescue teams to
find you to make sure that nobody
thought we were actually in an emergency
situation went out in in the Tahoe area
on to a place called Mar to speak it's
an 8000 200-foot mountain and we we
started out in the middle than iron 3 in
the morning because we wanted to get as
lost as possible in that and that worked
pretty well I was lost within half an
hour
I hiked for another like eight hours
trying to find something that I could
use as a waypoint but I really didn't I
was trying to the whole time to conceal
my tracks so that the search-and-rescue
guys couldn't find me I was climbing
over rocks mostly in packs no and then
what the snow is just about waist-deep I
put on snowshoes and dragged a dead
branch behind me to actually obscure my
footprints eventually got to the point
that I couldn't really go much longer
without water and without food I was
really just ready to go home the moment
help me help me
um I need waffles I got a waffle
emergency I pushed the 9-1-1 button and
they were there within a half an hour
you know it's kind of cheating because
they knew that I was gonna be out there
and the real real response time probably
a lot longer but I was still pretty
impressed that I was on a completely
different mountain than they thought I
was gonna be on and they still were able
you know literally within a half an hour
I see these snowmobiles come over the
rise and next thing I know I'm in a nice
warm snowcat drinking warm water that's
great